Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ich bin Markus. Ich moderiere das Chaosradio und das wird heute hier nicht in der ursprünglichen Form stattfinden, denn heute werden hier im Chaosradio feed wie der dicke Bretter gebohrt, zum zweiten und sicherlich auch nicht zum letzten Mal. In dicke Bretter soll erklärt werden, wie Gesetze und politische Initiativen zu digitalen Themen entstehen und wie Institutionen arbeiten, in denen Regeln, Urteile oder auch Regulierungen gemacht werden. Man könnte sagen, während das Chaosradio oft genug fragt, wer hat jetzt schon wieder genau was angezündet und wie löschen wir das, geht es in dicke Bretter eher darum, wer eigentlich die ganze Zeit Holz produziert und feinsäuberlich zu Scheiterhaufen aufstapelt. Dicke Bretter ist ein Podcast in Kooperation mit netzpolitik.org von und mit Elisa Lindinger, Elina Eickstädt und Constanze Kurz, der vom Chaosradio-Team produziert wurde. Aber genug von mir. Ich verschwinde jetzt wieder und wünsche euch viel Spaß mit dicke Bretter.
Willkommen, liebe Hörer und Hörerinnen zum Podcast Dicke Bretter. Wir kommen im Wechsel mit dem normalen Chaosradio und wollen euch ein bisschen informieren und vielleicht auch aktivieren, um sich zu interessieren, wie entstehen eigentlich Gesetze, Richtlinien, Verordnungen, wie entsteht eine politische Meinung und dafür haben wir jeweils immer bestimmte Themen. Und bevor wir zum heutigen Thema kommen, wollen wir uns vorstellen. Mein Name ist Constanze Kurz und bei mir zusammen sind Elisa Lindinger und Elina Eickstädt. Und Elina ist eigentlich heute unser super Spezialexperte, denn unser Thema soll die EU-Gesetzgebung sein im allerweitesten Sinne und gar nicht so stark von der rechtlichen Seite betrachtet, sondern eher von einer netzpolitisch-aktivistischen, weswegen wir auch ein bisschen über die Chatkontrolle reden wollen, ein aktuelles Gesetzgebungsverfahren. Aber wir wollen so ein bisschen die Institutionen beleuchten. Wir wollen uns auch ein bisschen so mit den typischen Begriffen, die in jedem Zusammenhang immer fallen, auseinandersetzen. Wir wollen die erklären und wir wollen auch ein bisschen hoffentlich ein bisschen Mut machen, sich selber einzubringen, wenn man sich für bestimmte Themen interessiert, die eben auf der EU-Ebene zum Gesetz oder zu einer Richtlinie werden. Wir empfehlen unsere erste Folge, die wir schon aufgenommen haben, die drehte sich um einen bestimmten Aspekt der Meinungsfindung bei den Vereinten Nationen. Das war unsere erste Folge und das hier ist die zweite. Und hoffentlich nicht die letzte. Okay, dann fangen wir mal thematisch an. Ich würde sagen, sinnvoll ist es sich zunächst mal, wenn man sich überlegt, wie entstehenden Gesetze oder Richtlinie oder auch politische Meinung im Allgemeinen in der EU, sich zu fragen, welche Institutionen sind am wichtigsten dabei und welche wollen wir wenigstens mal kurz ansprechen und dann später am Beispiel deutlich machen. Also wir haben zunächst mal, würde ich gleich sagen, allen bekannt, das EU-Parlament. Nicht wahr? Wollen wir das zuerst reden? Also klar, die Länder und natürlich über die Wahlen legitimiert entsenden Abgeordnete in ein großes EU-Parlament und das EU-Parlament ist letztlich auch eine entscheidende Säule in jedem Gesetzgebungsprozess, denn es muss zustimmen. Aber das Initiativrecht für bestimmte Gesetze oder jedenfalls in den meisten Fällen hat die EU-Kommission. Und die setzt sich zusammen aus verschiedenen, für inhaltliche Bereiche zuständigen EU-Kommissarern und Kommissarinnen. Und die, mit denen wir hier am meisten zu tun haben, die betreffen natürlich so in diesen Technologie- und digital- und netzpolitischen Bereichen immer dieselben. Und für Chatkontrolle, kommt die aus welchem Land aus?
Die kommt aus Schweden.
Schweden, ja. Und du heißt Johansson.
Genau. Und vielleicht für die meisten Bekannter ist die Kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der Leyen. Und da kann man jetzt vielleicht auch schon mal so einen kleinen Bogen schlagen zu, wie setzt sich die Kommission eigentlich zusammen? In der Kommission sind jeweils eine Kommissarin pro Land vertreten, die dann einen bestimmten Fachbereich hat. Das kann man sich so ein bisschen vorstellen, wie die Ministerin in Deutschland. Und Johansson ist die Ministerin für Inneres.
Und mit der haben wir öfter mal zu tun. Die wechseln aber natürlich, genauso wie wir es in Deutschland auch hätten, mit jeder Legislaturperiode. Und die läuft jetzt noch ungefähr ein Jahr für das Europaparlament und die EU-Kommission. Das ist erstmal nur ganz grob. Und die dritte sollte man mal nicht vergessen. Die ist eigentlich ebenso wichtig, muss man sagen. Und die ist auch so ein bisschen die Säule, wo die Regierungen eigentlich den meisten Einfluss nehmen auf die europäische Politik, nämlich der EU-Ministerrat. Und wie die ja schon heißt, aber oft verwechselt wird, sind da eben die Regierungen der einzelnen EU-Länder vertreten. Genau. Jetzt haben wir glaube ich die Säulen. Und wollen wir gleich mal ein bisschen, wollen wir das Beispiel Chatkontrolle schon nehmen oder wollen wir erstmal noch allgemein dabei bleiben? Ich würde sagen, wir nehmen jetzt schon mal die Chatkontrolle, denn die wollen wir als Beispiel so durchziehen. Und da können wir nämlich ganz gut praktisch zeigen, wie diese Institutionen ineinandergreifen. Also die Chatkontrolle ist nämlich genau von Johansson im Wesentlichen auch nach außen hin vertreten und ist von der Initiative der EU-Kommission, wie bei den meisten. Und an welchem Stadium des Gesetzgebungsprozesses sind wir der Rat?
Wir sind ja inzwischen schon relativ weit. Vielleicht sollten wir am Anfang anfangen. Du hast ja gerade irgendwie gesagt, Kommissarin Johansson hat das ganze Ding vorangetrieben. Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass die EU-Kommission hat das Initiativrecht für Gesetze. Es dauert aber manchmal ein bisschen, bis sie dieses Gesetz vorschlägt. Und die Chatkontrolle wird ja gerade auch unheimlich kontrovers diskutiert. Die wurde aber vorher auch schon in der Kommission unheimlich divers diskutiert. Und die haben tatsächlich schon 2021 damit angefangen, an diesem Gesetz herumzuschreiben und das versucht vorzubringen. Und es gab da sehr viele Bedenken, sehr viel Diskussionen. Aufgrund von vielen Gegebenheiten lag dann so ein bisschen Zeitdruck vor. Und dann haben sie am Ende jetzt diesen Gesetzesvorschlag gemacht. Der ist im Mai 2022 rausgekommen.
Das ist also auch schon wieder ein Jahr. Muss man mal sagen, wer das jetzt nicht weiß. Wir befinden uns gerade im Mai 2023.
Genau, und daran sieht man halt auch, dass EU-Gesetzgebungen ganz schöne Marathons sind. Und wir wissen auch gar nicht, ob wir überhaupt bis zu den EU-Wahlen fertig werden mit diesem Gesetz. Das ist total, naja, total ungewiss übertrieben. Das ist immer so ein bisschen die Frage, wie man fragt. Wenn man die Kommission fragen würde, würden die natürlich sagen, ja klar, Anfang 2024 haben wir das Ding durch und dann können wir loslegen. Wenn man sich jetzt aber die anderen Diskussionsstandorte anguckt, werden halt alle sagen, naja, das ist ein unheimlich kontroverses Gesetz. Da werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell auf den grünen Zweig kommen.
Jetzt würde ich mal sagen, wir biegen kurz ab. Also klar, wir wollen heute auch übersprechen, wie kommt so eine Gesetzgebung zustande. Aber wenn wir jetzt immer die Chatkontrolle am Beispiel nehmen, müssen wir kurz mal sagen, warum ist sie so kontrovers und was ist eigentlich das Vorhaben. Und wenn ich jetzt Johansson wäre, würde ich wahrscheinlich zu dem 20-minütigen Vortrag ansetzen und versuchen, also zu sagen oder zu beschreiben, wie schwierig die rechtliche Lage ist bei Verfolgung von Menschen, die Bilder oder Bewegtbilder, die Missbrauch von Kindern zeigen, verbreiten oder kaufen oder besorgen oder so. Und würde die zentrale Begründung damit anbringen. Weswegen nämlich diese Chatkontrolle gemacht werden soll, die dient im allerweitesten Sinne dem Kinderschutz und soll eben dieser Verbreitung dieser Bilder oder Bewegtbilder entgegenwirken. Und die Kritik, die wahrscheinlich in Deutschland schon viele gehört haben, aber die vermutlich in anderen europäischen Ländern weniger eine Rolle spielt, weil viel wesentlich weniger kontrovers debattiert wird, ist die weitgreifende Überwachung, die damit einhergeht. Das ist nicht die einzige Kritik, aber im Wesentlichen nämlich, dass sie vor allen Dingen für Chatdienste und neuerdings auch für Audionachrichten über diese Chatdienste einen Scan machen wollen.
Ja, also ich würde da einmal ganz kurz einhaken, weil ich glaube, das muss man vielleicht auch immer klarstellen, Chatkontrolle ist ein Extrem. Also es ist ein deutsches Wort und es ist auch das Wort, was es sozusagen in der deutschen Debatte prägt und diese Wahrnehmung. Und das Problem dabei ist, Chatkontrolle klingt immer sehr einseitig und das wird jetzt auch gerade in den deutschen Medien sehr geframed, dass das sozusagen das einzige Problem an diesem Gesetz ist. Das Problem ist aber wesentlich weitreichender. Insgesamt heißt also, ich sag mal, in der Brüssel-Bubble ist der Name von dieser Regulierung CISA, also Child Sexual Abuse Regulation, und die ist auch so genannt, der Name ist unheimlich lang und heißt halt nicht, wir wollen Kommunikation scannen. Und das Ziel und die Probleme, die da identifiziert werden im Hinblick auf Probleme von Kindesmissbrauchs und Gewalt gegen Kinder und auch die Verbreitung von Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen online, ist ja eine sehr wichtige und richtige Feststellung. Da sind wir uns auch alle sehr einig. Die Sachen, die jetzt für die Umsetzung angelegt werden, sind aber ziemlich schwierig zu bewerten. Und es ist halt nicht nur das Scannen von Chats dabei, sondern es sind auch Sachen wieder auf dem Tisch, die wir schon aus vergangenen Debatten kennen, wie Netzsperren, Uploadfilter und diverse anderen Themen, die wirklich schwierig sind. Und diese Diskussion über dieses Thema Audio ist super spannend.
Die sind echt nur zwei Tage alt oder so?
Das ist tatsächlich nicht neu. Das ist nur zu was geworden, was es eigentlich nicht ist. Die schwedische Ratspräsidentschaft hat in ihrer Darstellung vom 12. Mai gesagt, ja, und jetzt sind ganz viele Mitgliedstaaten dafür, Audiokommunikation zu inkludieren. Die eigentliche Debatte war aber, dass es Mitgliedstaaten gab, die gesagt haben, ihr Anderungsantrag an dieses Gesetz ist, Audiokommunikation explizit auszuschließen. Das ist eigentlich die Ursprungsdebatte. Daraus ist jetzt dieses Modell geworden, was so nicht ganz richtig ist. Und die Diskussion im Rat. Und jetzt kommen wir schon an so einen ersten intransparenten Punkt. Also diese Diskussionen im Rat finden hinter verschlossenen Türen statt. Und da habe ich als Bürgerin relativ wenig Einsicht, außer gute Journalistinnen kommen an die sogenannten Drahtberichte. Das sind sozusagen die Briefe nach Hause, die die Berichterstatterin an ihre Bundesregierung oder an ihre Regierungen schicken, in denen sie berichten, wie diese Sitzungen abgelaufen sind.
Und die heißen Drahtberichte, das ist noch so ein bisschen aus dieser alten Diplomatenzeit, wo man die noch über die Drahtnetzwerke geschickt hat. Aber ich will noch mal an der Stelle bleiben. Denn wir haben einen Begriff jetzt in Land, den wir bisher nicht hatten, nämlich die Ratspräsidentschaft. Und spielt nämlich auch noch bei all diesen Gesetzen oder jedenfalls sehr häufig. Die wechselt nämlich. Und damit ändert sich manchmal auch der Schwerpunkt. Und das ist auch gerade wieder passiert. Und wir müssen vielleicht mal reinbringen in diese Institution.
Ja, genau. Also die Ratspräsidentschaft wechselt alle sechs Monate. Momentan hat die Ratspräsidentschaft Schweden. Und die Schweden haben auch bei dem letzten, ich glaube, es war die Sitzung von den Innen- und Justizministern, so eine Willenserklärung veröffentlicht, in der sie sehr deutlich gemacht hat, dass sie eigentlich für mehr Überwachung von allem stehen. Und Ilva Johansson, das muss man vielleicht auch dazu sagen, ist auch eine schwedische Kommissarin. Also dementsprechend, oder sie ist die schwedische Kommissarin. Dementsprechend ist es auch nicht so verwunderlich, dass das irgendwie der Einfluss ist. Und was vielleicht auch an der Stelle noch ganz interessant ist, bei den Kommissarinnen, das sind, also anders als, im Rat sitzen halt permanent representatives, also permanente Repräsentationen, das sind Beamten, die sind nicht politisch. Die Kommissarinnen sind aber politisch. Und es kann halt auch einfach sein, und das ist zum Beispiel bei Elva Johansson jetzt der Fall für Schweden, dass die Kommissarin aus einer politischen Partei ist, die während der Wahlperiode nicht mehr zu der Regierungspartei gehört, weil es zwischendurch Wahlen gab. Das heißt, es kann schon sein, dass da Kommissarinnen sitzen, die eine sehr andere politische Meinung haben als die, die die Regierung vertritt. Und das ist bei uns eigentlich theoretisch auch der Fall mit Ursula von der Leyen.
Also wir haben ja keinen Kommissar in Deutschland, weil wir ja die Kommissionspräsidentin stellen. Aber das kommt natürlich auch mal vor, denn wie die meisten wissen, Ursula von der Leyen ist ja Christenunion, also konservativ. Und die Regierung ist ja nun mal bei der Weile die Ampel. Okay, aber wir waren noch eigentlich an dem Punkt, zu sagen, das ist die inhaltliche Kritik an der Chatkontrolle. Und wir haben es jetzt so getan, als wäre das eine Selbstverständlichkeit, weil wir, die wir hier sitzen, sind Gegner dieses Vorhabens, aber teilen natürlich das generelle Ziel. Aber ich finde halt, zumindest mal zu umreißen, ist schon wichtig, außer man muss in die mittlerweile viele Monate anhaltende Kritik und auch so ein bisschen die Berichterstattung zu verstehen. Denn die ist halt tatsächlich, wie Elina sagte, immer so ein bisschen auf diesen einzelnen Aspekt der Chatkontrolle reduziert. Aber das Vorhaben ist halt eigentlich sehr viel komplexer.
Ja, und ich glaube auch irgendwie, also Elisa und ich haben dazu ja auch schon mal einen Text geschrieben dazu, dass das halt irgendwie ein sehr, man sagt, textsolutionistischer Ansatz ist, den wir da sehen. Und dass das ja auch eher ein strukturelles Problem ist.
Ja, lass uns das gleich mal erklären. Warum ist das soluzionistisch? Was beschreibt der Begriff und warum ist es insbesondere bei diesem Fall hier so? Nee, wenn ihr nicht vorhersage, ecket. Also ich glaube, der Punkt dran ist, die suchen eine Lösung, die ihre Probleme erschlägt. Und diese Art Lösung gibt es schlicht nicht. Und schon gar nicht ohne enorme Nachteile für festgeschriebene Bürgerrechte, die in der EU-Karta stehen und die auch in der Menschenrechtskonvention stehen. Die suchen halt so eine magische Techniklösung. Und sie hören auch immer sehr gerne denjenigen zu, die ihnen das versprechen.
Ja, also ich glaube, es ist halt auch ein, ich glaube, es ist ein wirklicher Trend. Und ich finde den spannend. Und ich appelliere da immer gerne an Politikerinnen, da irgendwie mal nochmal fünf Minuten drüber nachzudenken. Also dieses Thema zu sagen, wir haben ein sehr, sehr vielschichtiges, sehr, sehr komplexes gesellschaftliches Problem, was auch die Frage von Kindesmissbrauch und Entstehung von Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellung ist. Und gerade im Hinblick auf die vergangene Pandemie auch irgendwie ein logisches Ergebnis der Pandemie ist, dass Missbrauch im sozialen Nahfeld zugenommen hat, weil einfach bestimmte Institutionen und Wirkungen nicht greifen konnten. Das ist ja eine sehr klare Geschichte. Und es ist natürlich auch verständlich, dass man sagt, oh, das ist total super, wir haben jetzt hier so eine Technologie und damit können wir alles erschlagen. Und ich glaube, es ist halt falsch auch einfach zu glauben, nur weil unsere Gesellschaft jetzt digitaler wird, dass wir die Probleme, die sich sozusagen in den digitalen Raum übersetzen, auch mit digitalen Mitteln lösen können vollständig.
Der Trend ist natürlich trotzdem da.
Und es gibt natürlich diverse Menschen, die dann sagen, ja, aber die Politikerinnen sehen ja auch, dass wir immer mehr technische Tools haben, die irgendwie auf magische Art und Weise Probleme lösen. Ja, aber das stimmt halt einfach nicht. Also klar, wir machen irgendwie Fortschritte mit Technologie, das steht völlig außer Frage. Man muss aber auch sehen, dass das natürlich auch immer mit gewissen Nachteilen kommt. Und dass es trotzdem so ist, dass wir diese Dinge, wenn wir sie wirklich nachhaltig lösen wollen, auch auf den Ebenen lösen müssen, auf denen sie entstehen. Und dass Technologie immer nur irgendwie vielleicht ein Hilfswerkzeug sein kann, irgendwie so in dem klassischen Gedanken, Hilfswissenschaft, Informatik. Und nicht die Wurze des Problems adressieren kann. Das funktioniert halt einfach nicht.
Jetzt sind wir ziemlich weit abgebogen eigentlich von dieser EU. Aber es lohnt sich vielleicht insofern, dass die Chatkontrolle nicht die einzige Beispielgesetzgebung ist, wo diese Art Gedanken Anwendung finden. Mir kommt es halt oft so vor, dass die Diskussionen vor zehn Jahren in derselben Art geführt wurden. Ich finde es erstaunlich, wie das so wiedergänger sind. Deswegen hat es sich vielleicht gelohnt, jetzt mal kurz abzubiegen.
Ja, und ich glaube, zwar vor zehn Jahren wurde das auch schon diskutiert, ich glaube aber, dass es immer mehr Tech-Anwendungen gibt, die auch näher an die Nutzerinnen rücken, also die auch zugänglicher sind für alle. Dass das Ding noch, dieser Tech-Technologie-Glaube teilweise noch verstärkt wird. Weil jetzt kann ich es ja irgendwie anfassen und selber benutzen. Und es sind nicht mehr diese drei versprengten Nerds, die irgendwie damit Sachen machen, sondern ChatGPT kann mir ja auch mal alle meine Fragen beantworten, um es jetzt die ganze Überspitze zu sagen.
Na ja, also, wie gesagt, ihr und ich und viele weitere Kritiker haben darüber geschrieben. Das kann man sich durchlesen, die verschiedenen Aspekte der Kritik. Es gibt sehr viele, auch juristische Stellungnahmen mittlerweile, die die Grundrechtswidrigkeit dieses Vorhabens in den Fokus rücken. Und man muss auch noch mal was anderes sagen, glaube ich, die Who-is-Who der IT-Security-Welt hat sich gegen dieses Vorhaben aufgestellt. Nicht nur, weil Europa das plant, sondern auch, weil es parallele Ideen gibt, die etwa aus Großbritannien kommen, aber auch in den USA. Also, es ist ja nicht so, dass wir irgendwie die einzigen Verspreckenkritiker sind, sondern wir haben auf der Seite eigentlich alle Leute, die sich im Bereich der IT auskennen. Und die Nachteile dieser Idee, die da drinsteckt, nicht nur die Chatkontrolle an sich, aber auch die anderen Maßnahmen, die in dem Paket drin sind, sehr negativ bewerten, aus guten Gründen.
Dann ist doch das Spannende auch noch mal zu fragen, wer sind denn diejenigen, die es propagieren? Du hast gerade gesagt, da gibt es immer die Akteurinnen, die irgendwie sagen, wir haben ja das, weiß nicht, was die Eier legende Wolme ist, aber gefunden. Wer argumentiert denn dafür, wenn alle dagegen sind?
Also ich glaube, das eine ist, wir haben immer, das muss man vielleicht generell betrachten, bei den EU-Gesetzgebungen, wir haben oft eine Fraktion, die kommt aus dem Bereich der inneren Sicherheit, das sind Strafverfolgungsbehörden, das sind Geheimdienste, diese Bereiche. Aber es sind doch oft Strukturkonservative, die immer wieder diesen, ja, aber generell auch sehr totalitäre Überwachungsideen da durchdrücken wollen. Da sind aber auch oft, ich nenne jetzt mal, Schrafermittlungspraktiker dabei und Polizeigewerkschafter, die natürlich, der Fokus von deren Arbeit ist Verbrecher fangen. Und die sehen auch oft nur Verbrecher. Da verliert sich oft die Verhältnismäßigkeit der Mittel. Wir haben aber auch sehr, sehr häufig auch klassische kommerzielle Akteure, die hier mitspielen. Denn es gibt natürlich auch einen Bereich, ich nenne jetzt mal einen kommerziellen Bereich, der hier verspricht, sie können die Lösung anbieten. In diesem speziellen Fall der Chatkontrolle ist es aber so, dass die betroffenen Konzerne, die ja hier auch die großen Tech-Konzerne sind, meistens US-Amerikanische, aber nicht nur, wissen wir ja, mit was wir so kommunizieren, die sind hier nicht gerade auf der Seite der Kommissaren.
Nee, und da muss man halt auch einfach sagen, also das haben wir jetzt so noch nicht so spezifisch benannt, aber Chatkontrolle würde halt aktuell, nachdem auch was vorgeschlagen ist und wie der Stand der Technik so aussehen, sogenanntes Client-Site-Scanning bedeuten. Und die Kommission stellt es gerne so dar, dass Apple ja schon mal eine Client-Site-Scanning-Lösung hatte und diese nur zurückgezogen hat, weil es so viel Protest von der Zivilgesellschaft gab. Das entspricht allerdings nicht der Realität. Also alle Technologie-Expertinnen sind sich da sehr einig, inklusive den Leuten von Apple, dass es auch einfach ein technisches Desaster war und dass es aufgrund dieses Fiascos zurückgezogen wurde. Und das ist da irgendwie immer ganz wichtig zu verstehen. Dennoch, und das ist halt wirklich spannend, ist es so, dass natürlich irgendwie wirklich diese, ich sag mal, die Big Tech und die Marktführerinnen in diesem ganzen Bereich, alle sagen so, wir halten das jetzt für nicht so eine wahnsinnig schlaue Idee. Man muss dazu sagen, die scannen jetzt teilweise schon, aber auf einem anderen Level als das, was dieser Entwurf vorsieht. Und sie machen das freiwillig. Das heißt, sie müssen es nicht tun. Und die Menschen...
Die müssen vor allen Dingen ihre Technik nicht umbauen, um das zu tun.
Genau. Und die, ich sag mal, die kommerziellen Akteure, die jetzt ein Interesse daran haben, dass es gescannt oder Scanning-Technologien gibt, das ist schon sehr spannend, weil das ist eine Organisation von Ashton Kutcher. Ashton Kutcher kennt man irgendwie so aus, ey Mann, wo ist mein Auto? Und ich weiß nicht, ist das die wilden 70er oder so?
Das sind Filme, wer jetzt diese Titel nicht kennt.
Genau, es ist ein Hollywood-Schauspieler, der tatsächlich auch in den frühen Tagen auch sehr viel in Uber und solche Start-ups investiert hat.
Er ist auch ein Business Angel.
Genau, er ist ein Business Angel und jetzt rettet dieser Angel die Kinder.
Der war auch da, der ist auch extra hingefahren nach Brüssel.
Nicht nur einmal, also das ist wirklich interessant. Vielleicht können wir da jetzt nochmal diese Verbindung zu der EU-Gesetzgebung zurückzumachen. Ich habe ja gesagt, die Kommission hat relativ lange daran gearbeitet und so. Und Kommissarin Johansson ist halt primär federführend dafür zuständig gewesen. Und sie hat sich tatsächlich kein einziges Mal mit Vertretern der Zivilgesellschaft getroffen. Während dieser Zeit, das ist relativ ungewöhnlich, muss man sagen. Denn in der Regel, wenn die Kommission solche Entwürfe macht, holt sie sich das Feedback auch von unterschiedlichen Stakeholdern ein.
Aber ganz stimmt das nicht? Also wenn man jetzt zu den zivilgesellschaftlichen Akteuren auch Kinderschutzverbände zählen würde, hat sie die schon getroffen. In Deutschland ist es aber so, dass die Kinderschutzverbände sich nicht auf die Seite von Johansson geschlagen haben.
Und normalerweise ist es aber auch so, wenn es so einen Konsultationsprozess gibt und Stakeholder treffen und wenn du dann als zivilgesellschaftlicher Stakeholder sagst, liebe Kommission, wir würden gerne uns mal mit dir darüber unterhalten, dann sagt die Kommission in der Regel ja, es kann sein, dass du nicht unbedingt einen Termin mit der Kommissarin selber kriegst, aber mit dem Fachpersonal. Und das haben wir tatsächlich gemacht, auch im Vorfeld. Und wir hatten kein einziges Meeting. Haben kein einziges Meeting. Es gibt eine schöne Webseite, die heißt Have Elva Johansson met yet. Die sollten wir nachher verlinken. Aber mit Ashton Kutcher hat sie sich glaube ich sogar zwei oder drei Mal getroffen. Die sind auch extra in Silicon Valley geflogen, teilweise für Meetings mit ihm. Und der war jetzt auch schon mehrfach im EU-Parlament, hat auch Selfies gemacht, gab sehr viel Selfies. Und jetzt um nochmal darauf zu kommen, was hat Ashton Kutcher eigentlich damit zu tun? Ashton Kutcher hat eine Kinderschutzorganisation gegründet, die heißt Thorn. Und zu Thorn gehört ein Startup, ein Tech-Startup im weitesten Sinne, würde ich sagen, das heißt Safer. Und Safer macht damit Werbung. Man weiß nicht genau, ob deren Werbepitch auf die Regulierung zugeschneidert wurde oder die Regulierung auf deren Werbepitch oder beides.
Parallel.
Aber Safer stellt Technologien zur Verfügung. Sie framet auf ihrer eigenen Website eine Full-Allround-Contentmoderationslösung, die aber genau das gewährleisten soll, was in dieser Regulierung vorgesehen ist. Das heißt, das Scannen nach bekannten und unbekannten Material und Grooming. Und auch eine Suite, die dir vollumfängliche Funktionen für Contentmoderationen mit einem menschlichen Contentmoderator in diesem Prozess zur Verfügung stellt.
Und mit einer hohen Genauigkeit, die der versprochen wird. Da geht es ja auch immer darum.
Das haben die tatsächlich so in ihrem Pitch nicht drinstehen?
Gesprochen hat er schon drüber.
Genau, also er behauptet es immer. Und das ist wahnsinnig interessant, wo auch wirklich alle Experten, die in diesem Bereich forschen, sagen, das funktioniert nicht. Also die Genauigkeiten von den gängigen Lösungen, also das ist zum Beispiel von Microsoft, das ist FotoDNA und anderen, das kann vorne und hinten nicht stimmen. Und ich hatte tatsächlich auch ja schon mit Leuten von Safer zu tun. Und die begründen das damit, dass sie ja den Threshold verändern können. Das ist total lustig. Vielleicht zum Threshold, dieser Threshold sagt sozusagen, wie empfindlich dieser Scanner ist, um Bilder zu erkennen. Und sie sagen dann halt, okay, dann machen wir den Threshold halt so, dass er nicht so leicht anschlägt. Und dann haben wir natürlich auch weniger Falschmeldungen.
Wir haben vor allen Dingen immer viel mehr falsch-positive. Also wenn du den Thresholds einlernst, dann werden auch sehr viel mehr reinfallen, die sie gar nicht meinten.
Nee, genau andersrum. Der Idee ist ja zu sagen, sie machen, sie detekten insgesamt weniger. Dann heißt das nämlich, dann schießen sie sich eigentlich ins eigene Knie, weil sie sozusagen mehr durchgehen, die hätten eigentlich gescannt werden müssen. Genau, das ist nämlich die Diskussion, die wir mit denen haben. Das ist aber auch sehr auffällig in dieser Gesamtdebatte. Ich sag mal so, ein paar Sachen sind einfach wirklich so Statistik 101, wo man relativ schnell weiß, das kann so nicht funktionieren, aber das ist halt, wenn es in so einem von Ashton Kutcher-Wein vorgetragen wird, und der sagt, das ist irgendwie ganz einfach. Spotify macht das auch so, weil glaube ich, das ist ein letztes Ding, was total absurd ist. Dann glauben die Leute das leider. Also man muss halt am Ende des Tages sagen, Ashton Kutcher ist halt ein Schauspieler und ein guter Entertainer.
Er ist vor allen Dingen ein Pomi. Der hat diese Seite der Argumentation mit sehr viel Presse breitgetreten. Also am Ende glaube ich, wird die Leute sich noch nicht vorstellen können, dass 9% oder Bruchteile von Prozent in ganzen Zahlen viele Millionen Falschmeldungen sind. Also da ist ja einfach die Relation so riesig, weil in Europa haben wir 450 Millionen Menschen und so gut wie alle benutzen mittlerweile irgendwie Messaging-Systeme. Da sind immer gleich Millionen betroffen. Aber ich bin nochmal zurück, du hast ein paar Mal wir gesagt und ich würde gerne darauf kurz eingehen, wer du mit wir meinst. Du hast gemeint, also wir schreiben mal der Kommissarin, in diesem Fall Johansson, das könnte man jetzt auch für andere Gesetzgebungsproteste sehen. Wer ist denn hier wir? Also wir werden jetzt nicht den Fass aufmachen, wer macht da Lobby? Sondern wer ist hier wir und wie?
Und hattet ihr auch einen Schauspieler dabei?
Genau, hattet ihr auch Schauspieler.
Ich müsste mal Kate Winslet fragen. Sorry, das war ein unrelated Joke. Also wir, das haben wir jetzt gerade am Anfang nicht gesagt. Ich bin genauso wie Konz, Sprecherin vom CCC. Und der CCC macht ja sehr viel, ich sag mal, deutsche Begleitung von deutsch problematischen netzpolitischen Themen. Und da nehmen wir auch Stellung zu. Aber genauso wie mit der UN und dadurch, dass unsere Gesellschaft irgendwie immer mehr mit Digitalthemen beschäftigt wird, ist natürlich auf der EU-Ebene auch relativ viel los. Ich glaube, so das Prominenteste war diese ganze Debatte um Artikel 13 und Uploadfilter.
Oder die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Oder die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Also genau, es gab schon das eine oder andere prominente Thema. Aber es ist natürlich völlig klar. Es ist natürlich, EU ist ja nochmal sozusagen ein ganz anderes Spielfeld. Das merken wir jetzt auch im Vergleich zu Deutschland. Und es gibt auch eine europäische Dachorganisation. Das ist die EDIRI, die European Digital Rights. Ich habe vergesst immer schon, wie viele Mitglieder wir haben. Es sind sehr, sehr viele inzwischen. Es ist inzwischen eine sehr große Organisation.
Man kann sagen, mehr als EU-Mitglieder auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich glaube, es sind...
Wir müssen mal nachgucken. Können wir ja dann als flink nachreichen?
Genau. Auf jeden Fall EDIRI gibt es mittlerweile aber auch schon seit 20 Jahren. Also vielleicht zum Vergleich. Der Klub ist 42 dieses Jahr geworden. Oder wird 42?
Ja, man muss immer sehen, diese Organisation, das ist im Klub nicht anders als bei EDIRI. Die wachsen, die ändern ihre Profile, die professionalisieren sich. Und bei EDIRI ist da einfach auch ein großer Sprung. Die finanzieren sich heute anders, die sind echt aktiv. Und ihr kommt ja gerade von der General Assembly. Die treffen sich jetzt auch einmal. Wollt ihr dazu oder wollen wir dafür nicht...
Genau, also vielleicht kann man noch mal kurz was sagen. Also EDIRI ist die Dachverband. EDIRI hat auch ein Büro in Brüssel. Und EDIRI hat auch ein sehr großes Team inzwischen. Ich glaube, es sind fast 20 Leute.
Haben wir irgendwie auch eins in Straßburg oder nur in Brüssel?
Wir haben nur eins in Brüssel.
Die meisten wissen, wir haben es jetzt hier nicht erwähnt.
Genau, das Parlament zieht um. Aber die meisten Sachen, die für uns interessant sind, passieren in Brüssel. Und wir haben halt sozusagen... Also EDIRI ist schon inzwischen sehr professionalisiert. Sie haben ein wesentlich größeres Team, was sie da haben. Sie haben sowohl Leute, die zur deutschen Politikberaterin sind. Das sind inzwischen sechs oder sieben Personen. Sie haben auch ein Team, das sich um Kampagnen kümmert.
Sie sind vor allen Dingen im Club, vom Club unterschiedlich. Sie sind hauptamtliche. Während der CPC komplett ehrenamtlich arbeitet, sind einfach Leute bezahlt, den ganzen Tag diese Arbeit zu machen.
Und das ist halt, ja?
Und das ist eine Mitgliederorganisation, ne? Also, da ist nicht nur das zum einen natürlich dieses sehr, sehr schlagkräftige und vor Ort aktive Team von E3 selber. Aber die haben natürlich auch diese Herrscher an teilweise ehrenamtlichen, teilweise hauptamtlichen Organisationen, die in allen, in EU-Mitgliedstaaten und weit darüber hinaus quasi nochmal vernetzt sind und dort aktiv sind. Und die ja auch nochmal Energie und Wissen und so weiter mit reingeben können.
Das muss man halt auch E3 sehr zugute halten. Sie koordinieren das halt auch. Und sie schauen halt auch. Das ist jetzt zum Beispiel für uns als Club total der große Vorteil. Sie gucken, okay, ihr seid eine ehrenamtliche Organisation. Der Club hat aber relativ viel Schlagkraft natürlich. Wenn wir irgendwo auftauchen und eine Stellungabnahme abnehmen, dann fällt das schon ins Gewicht, auch auf EU-Ebene. Und jetzt im konkreten Fall bei der Chatkontrolle ist es in dem, ich sag mal, in dem Policy-Bereich, die meine Kollegin von E3M, Ella Jakubowska, die sozusagen verantwortlich ist für dieses Pfeil, mit der ich halt aber auch alles koordiniere. Das heißt, Ella hat sozusagen den großen Überblick über alles, was passiert, die ist in Brüssel vor Ort und organisiert eine Menge und hat einfach ganz, ganz viel Hintergrundwissen. Und dadurch kann ich halt auch sehr gezielt in diesem ganzen Bereich agieren. Und ich glaube, das ist halt wirklich so der große Gewinn, den wir durch E3 haben. Wir haben Leute, die sich auch irgendwie so ein Stück weit als Dienstleister für uns verstehen, um vor Ort eine Situation zu schaffen, dass wir auch als Ehrenamtliche da sehr aktiv partizipieren können und auch alle Informationen haben, um uns sinnvoll einzubringen in den Prozess.
Die haben vielleicht noch etwas, was man immer nicht vergessen darf. Wenn man da ein Büro hat, dann kennt man einfach die Menschen. So wie das hier in Berlin im Bundestag ist, dass man einfach die Akteure auch persönlich kennt, so ist es in Brüssel letztlich ja auch ein gewisser Kosmos. Und wenn man da viel unterwegs ist, dann kennt man die Leute. Und zwar nicht nur die Abgeordneten oder die Berichterstatter oder so, sondern auch die Mitarbeiter. Man kennt die Journalisten, die sich damit auskennen. Das sind ein bisschen diese Netzwerken, wo man einfach auch Informationen bekommt. Und selbst die, was vorhin die Drahtberichte erwähnt oder so, selbst die, die eigentlich nicht für die Öffentlichkeit sein wollen, geraten zumindest und teilen dann auch in dieses Netzwerk, der, ich nenne es jetzt mal, aktivisten Lobbyisten. Ist ja eigentlich keine klassische Lobbyarbeit, aber weil sie eben aktivistisch motiviert ist, aber letztlich ist es ja doch eine Form von Lobbyismus. Und ich glaube, das sollte man nicht vergessen, dass das einen großen Unterschied macht, dass da jemand sitzt physisch. Du bist auch oft hingeflogen. Ich bin gefahren, möchte ich bitte betonen. Also Elina und Elisa sind beide natürlich schon öfter mal in Brüssel. Ich weiß, ich war selber auch öfter mal in Brüssel, aber es war das andere, dort einfach so day-to-day-Work zu machen. Das andere ist wichtiger, scheint mir manchmal auch noch, die übersetzen manchmal Sachen, also die aktivistischen Texte. Das ist manchmal mit einer gewissen Latenz und so, das ist nicht immer am selben Tag, aber ich glaube, da versucht man diese mangelnde europäische gesamtgesellschaftliche Debatte irgendwie auszugleichen, dass man zumindest sie zusammenholt. Denn viele von den Organisationen in Idri sind halt in ihrem Land sehr klein. Also sie sind jetzt nicht alle super schlagkräftig und werden gehört, sondern teilweise noch im Aufbau oder haben auch manchmal einfach echt wenig Leute. Insofern ist diese Charnierfunktion nämlich echt wichtig.
Ja, und ich glaube, das darf man, ich glaube, das vergessen Leute, oder vergisst man in Deutschland häufig. Die Debatten in Deutschland werden einfach grundsätzlich anders geführt als in anderen EU-Ländern.
Ja doch, ich denke das auch.
Also ich sag mal so, also das sieht man jetzt, also ich glaube bei der Chatkontrolle sieht man das jetzt gerade sehr gut. Die deutsche Debatte ist in Anführungsstrichen relativ klar.
Und sie ist vor allen Dingen nicht nur akademisch. Wenn ich mir das angucke für den englischsprachigen Raum, sind das halt viele Wissenschaftler oder die mit den Wissenschaftlern verbunden, IT-Sicherheitsforschern. Bei uns ist das eigentlich durchaus in den Zeitungen, nicht in allen. Aber es ist zum Teil eine öffentliche Debatte, die sieht man auch immer so an den Zahlen, wenn es Petitionen gibt. Da sind immer viele Deutsche unterwegs.
Genau, also einerseits ist das total gut für uns in Deutschland, andererseits ist es total schlecht für Europa manchmal. Weil der Hang an deutschen Datenschutzmenschen überwiegt. Und die haben auch einfach eine sehr privilegierte Sicht auf die Dinge. Weil die denken, ja, das ist ja total trivial, dass das ein Problem ist. Und es ist auch total trivial, dass das die Gesamtgesellschaft als Problem wahrnimmt. Aber wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel in die Niederlande gucken, oder auch manchmal nach Österreich, in diesem Fall ist es ein bisschen anders in Österreich, dann ist es schon anders. Andererseits muss man halt sagen, du hast von eben Scharnierfunktion, von Edri gesagt, mach das, also manchmal ist es einfach gut, dass du trotzdem eine Organisation aus einem Land hast, wo die Debatte vielleicht nicht so klar ist, wo du aber sehr gezielt an EU-Parlamentsabgeordnete rantreten kannst mit der Organisation. Weil manchmal ist es halt auch einfach dieses, okay, da sind Leute aus meinem Land, die sich fundiert und schlau Gedanken dazu machen und die mir die Argumente liefern kann. Das ist manchmal auch enorm hilfreich. Und manchmal ist es dann halt auch einfach so, dass es klar ist, wir werden jetzt in diesem Land nicht irgendwie das Mobilisationspotenzial haben, wie wir es in Deutschland haben. Aber wir haben eine sehr kleine Gruppe an Personen mit... Experten, die wir noch an die Abgeordneten bringen können. Einfach weil sie zum Beispiel, also dieses United in Diversity, wir haben dieses Sprachproblem häufig in Europa, die die Sprache der Abgeordneten sprechen. Und das ist tatsächlich, man denkt immer, das ist total natürlich, dass wir in Brüssel alle Englisch sprechen miteinander. Das ist aber nicht der Fall. Also das wirkt schon nochmal anders, wenn ich da jemanden hinschicken kann, keine Ahnung, der zum Beispiel Griechisch sprechen kann und mit einem griechischen Abgeordneten auf Griechisch über das Problem sprechen kann. Und in der Regel nehmen die Abgeordneten sich ja auch die Zeit.
Ja, haben wir da eigentlich mal auch einen leeren Schweden bei Edri? Wer ist denn die Schwedische?
Die Schweden sind sehr aktiv. Die haben ja eine eigene Kampagne auch in Schweden. Mit dem Mulward-VPN. Und denen ist tatsächlich was gelungen. Oh, die haben ja den ganzen Flughafen in Stockholm mit Plakaten geflastert. Und das haben sie zu der Zeit gemacht, als es den Wechsel zur Ratspräsidentschaft gab. Das heißt, da sind gerade eh relativ viele EU-Politiker in Stockholm am Airport angekommen. Und das war ein enormer Cool, das war extrem cool. Und die Debatte ist tatsächlich auch gekippt.
Ja, wir fanden das jetzt cool. Ob die das so cool fanden, weiß ich nicht.
Nein, aber in Schweden ist ja das Interessante. Wir hatten in Schweden ja gerade Wahlen. Und Eva Johansson ist Teil der Sozialdemokraten in Schweden. Aber es sind ja jetzt sozusagen die Konservativen in Schweden an die Macht gekommen. Und die sind tatsächlich ein Großteil. Wir haben jetzt, ich glaube, drei oder vier konservative Abgeordnete und auch die schwedische Regierung, die anfängt, sich gegen die Chatkontrolle auszusprechen. Das liegt aber nicht daran, dass sie Konservative sind, die auf einmal irgendwie ihren Gedanken gut gewechselt haben, sondern einfach, dass sie was gegen ihre sozialdemokratische Kommissarin haben. Also das hat teilweise auch ein bisschen politische Hintergründe.
Also innenpolitische eigentlich, ja.
Genau.
Na gut, aber wenn man das ein bisschen generalisieren will, dann kann man natürlich sagen, wenn man sich so eine Gesetzgebung ansieht und der jeweilige Kommissar oder die Kommissarin sind da sehr aktiv drin. Das ist ja auch unterschiedlich, habe ich so und so erlebt. Denn dann lohnt es sich natürlich auch mal zu gucken, ob man da jemand in dem Land aktivieren kann oder wenn sich eben die Ratspräsidentschaft ändert. Aber jetzt müssen wir noch zu einer anderen Ebene kommen. Ich habe die schon mal fallen lassen, aber die auch eine große Rolle spielt. Bei der Chatkontrolle, aber auch bei allen anderen. Nämlich, wenn es in die Ausschüsse geht. Wir sind jetzt eigentlich den Weg nicht weiter.
Genau, also wir können ja vielleicht noch mal von vorne anfangen.
Von vorne können wir nicht anfangen.
Doch, ich mache jetzt mal kurz Pause. Die Chatkontrolle wurde am 11. Mai 2022 vorgestellt.
Mit dem Vorlauf, den du schon erwähnt hast, den wir jetzt aber nicht weiter besprechen.
Nein, ich wollte jetzt da weitermachen. Weil du hast jetzt die ganze Zeit Ausschüsse gesagt und keiner weiß, was Ausschüsse sind.
Und Berichterstatter.
Und Berichterstatter und alles Mögliche. Und was sind eigentlich Schatten? Also was passiert eigentlich, wenn so ein EU-Gesetz vorgestellt wird? Also dieses Gesetz wird vorgestellt. Und dann geht es, wir haben ja sozusagen unsere drei Entitäten. Die Kommission ist dann erst mal so ein bisschen raus. Die haben ihr, haben ihr Ding, ihren Anteil geleistet. Die haben das abgegeben. Und dann geht es an den Rat und an das Parlament.
Ah, eins muss ich noch erwähnen. Es geht noch an eine dritte. Also an viele Entitäten, nämlich die haben mittlerweile die Pflicht, die nationalen Parlamente zeitgleich zu informieren. Das heißt, der Bundestag erfährt das auch. Wie der aufgenommen wird, ist eine andere Frage. Aber die Information, dass diese Sitzung stattgefunden hat, geht auch sofort an die nationalen Parlamente. Das ist eine Form der parlamentarischen Beteiligung.
Genau, und da ist vielleicht auch noch mal zu sagen, wichtig zu sagen, und das ist in dem Bereich der Chatkontrolle auch vielleicht interessant, es gibt Länder in der EU, wo Abstimmung in den Parlamenten bindend für die Regierung und ihr Verhalten im Rat sein können.
Je nach Politbereich muss man sagen.
Genau, also in Österreich ist es zum Beispiel so, dass das Parlament eine Abstimmung machen kann, haben sie auch gemacht zur Chatkontrolle.
Als einziges europäisches Land.
Das haben die Deutschen immer noch nicht hingekriegt. Und bei den Deutschen ist es auch nicht binden, das ist noch mal ein bisschen anders, aber die Österreicher haben das tatsächlich geschafft, eine Abstimmung zu machen im Parlament gegen die Chatkontrolle mit einer Weisung, an die sich diese permanenten Repräsentantinnen im Rat halten müssen.
Aber wir waren ja noch bei der Ebene. Ich habe das jetzt noch eingeschoben.
Also, Gesetz wird vorgestellt, es geht an den Rat, und im Rat gibt es tatsächlich auch Facharbeitsgruppen. Die Facharbeitsgruppe im Rat, die jetzt gerade das diskutiert, bevor das dann weiter gereicht wird, ist die Law Enforcement Working Group, also Schafferfolgungsbehörden in Politik. Also, da sitzen bei uns Vertreterinnen aus dem BMI, die das mitverhandeln.
Das ist auch immer so eine Sache, die wir jetzt hier nicht weiter besprechen, aber die spielt bei manchen netzpolitischen Gesetzgebungsformen natürlich eine Rolle, dass die EU nur in bestimmten Bereichen Kompetenzen hat, wo sie was regeln darf. Und das ist im Bereich der inneren Politik und bei der Strafverfolgung nicht immer so gegeben, und da müssen sie manchmal Grenzen beachten. Sie dürfen also nicht zu weit in manche Bereiche reinregieren, die von den Verträgen, die die EU-Staaten miteinander geschlossen haben, nicht gedeckt sind. Aber im Teilbereich, wie man hier sieht, können sie regeln. Das ist aber durchaus teilweise in den juristischen Gutachten besprochen worden, dass die ihre Kompetenzen manchmal etwas ausweiten. Mehr als sie vielleicht dürften.
Genau, und das kann man vielleicht auch noch sagen, dass die juristische Grundlage für die Chatkontrolle ist tatsächlich der interne Markt. Also es ist...
Binnenmarkt, sagt man immer.
Binnenmarkt, genau. Es ist Artikel 114 des Treaty of Functioning of the EU.
Okay, also die Artikel kenne ich jetzt natürlich.
Also das Treaty of the Functioning of the EU ist sozusagen Teil des Lissaboner Vertrags tatsächlich.
Jetzt sieht man mal, Elina steckt da echt tief drin.
Ich bin ein Nerd, ich nehme mir das sehr ernst. Aber das vielleicht an der Stelle, es ist tatsächlich, diese Regulierung, und das passt zu dieser strukturellen Kritik nochmal, bezieht sich nur auf Binnenmarkt-Dinge. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt fordern würde, wir möchten mehr Ressourcen für Kinderschutz, dann könnten sie das mit dieser Regulierung nicht abdecken, weil das kein Problem des Binnenmarktes ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so verständlich ist. Das muss man vielleicht noch mal genauer erklären. Wenn man angenommen als Kritiker dieses Vorschlags, würde man sagen, alternativ haben wir Vorschläge. Und zwar, und dann zählt man eine Liste auf, wie man Kinder stärken und Schutzmaßnahmen verbessern will, die vielen dann aber politisch in anderen Bereichen. Das ist sozusagen auch Problematik, wenn man Kritik übt, die aus diesem Bereich rausfällt. Die wird dennoch viel geäußert, gerade auch von den Kinderschutzverbänden.
Weil sie natürlich national wirkt. Wir haben sie gerade schon gehört, viel Aktivismus muss auch national stattfinden, weil am Ende da ja auch noch mal Einflussmöglichkeiten bestehen, die vielleicht jetzt noch gar nicht so richtig greifen oder in Österreich schon ganz gut funktioniert haben. Aber da ist natürlich das Argument dann total valide und deswegen ist da glaube ich auch eine Koordination total gut.
Genau. Aber das sozusagen ist der Ratteil. Und dann kommen wir jetzt zu Constanze Sausschüssen.
Ich habe mit diesen Ausschüssen auch selten zu tun, nur manchmal.
Ich weiß gar nicht, du kannst die Parallelen immer besser ziehen zu deutschen Gesetzgebungsprozessen als ich. Aber es ist halt so, wenn das an das Parlament geht, dann ist es nicht so, dass es so direkt im Parlament diskutiert wird. Sondern das Parlament hat auch seine eigenen Fachausschüsse. In der Regel gibt es immer einen federführenden Ausschuss, der sozusagen einen Bericht abgibt. Das heißt, Report in dem ganzen EU-Sprech. Das klingt immer total fancy. Am Anfang habe ich auch gedacht, cool. Erst mal, wenn es ein Report ist, dann denkt man immer ein bisschen an Prosa und Erklärungen. Es ist aber viel langweiliger und viel schlimmer. Es ist nämlich einfach nur eine Liste von Änderungsanträgen an das Gesetz, wie es aussieht.
Also man muss sich jetzt praktisch vorstellen, viele, viele Seiten, die auch nicht unbedingt kohärent sind. Weil aus verschiedenen Ecken Vorschläge kommen. Es steht auch immer dran, wer die gemacht hat. Aber es ist nicht unbedingt ein gut lesbarer Bericht, sondern es ist eher so eine Stückelung an Änderungsvorschlägen.
Du hast jetzt schon gesagt, von vielen Ecken. Das ist ja dann schon das Endprodukt. Man muss sozusagen von vorne anfangen. Also wir haben das Gesetz, das Gesetz wurde vorgestellt, und dann wird es an Ausschüsse weitergegeben. Und es gibt genau einen verantwortlichen Ausschuss. Bei der Chatkontrolle ist es der Liebeausschuss. Das ist der...
Bürgerliche Freiheiten.
Bürgerliche Freiheiten und Inneres tatsächlich.
Den haben wir wirklich am meisten zu... Also auch über die Personen, die da drin sitzen, hinweg, weil sich das natürlich über die Jahre nicht ändert, dass die immer wieder für unsere Themen zuständig sind. Und die sind übrigens auch meistens ziemlich die Coolen. Also wenn man jetzt mal auf den Parlament im Allgemeinen guckt, also wer setzt sich in einen Ausschuss für Bürgerliche Freiheiten, da hat man oft eine Menge an Menschen, die durchaus ein ähnliches Mindset hat und meistens zumindest auch ein großes Interesse für den Themenbereich.
Genau, also das war sozusagen unser erster Ausgangspunkt. Das Liebe-Komitee hat das bekommen. Und dann ist was passiert, was tatsächlich auch relativ häufig bei EU-Gesetzen passiert. Es gibt natürlich noch mehr Komitees, mehr Ausschüsse.
Meistens eigentlich zwei sind es. Also ich habe sehr geredet, dass es fünf sind oder so.
Nee, also es gibt ja immer sozusagen das, was sozusagen verantwortlich ist. Und dann gibt es ja die, die sozusagen noch eine Meinung dazu haben können. Und dann sind es mehrere. Es ist, das ist eine sehr interessante Gemengelage aktuell tatsächlich, weil das Problem ist, wenn es sozusagen ein Ausschuss gibt, der die Verantwortung bekommt und ein anderer Ausschuss das anfechtet. Hat auch wieder was mit dem Treaty of Functioning of the EU zu tun, warum die das können. Dann kommt es meistens zu einer Verzögerung im Gesetzesprozess. Und das kann auch manchmal eine sehr lange Verzögerung sein. Das war beim AI-Act tatsächlich so. Und deswegen sind sie aktuell auch manchmal ein bisschen vorsichtiger, damit solche Sachen anzufechten, wenn sie nicht wollen, dass es an dieser Stelle zu einer Verzögerung kommt. Es ist aber nichtsdestotrotz bei der Chatkontrolle passiert. Und das ist auch irgendwie logisch, wenn, ich habe vorhin gesagt, das ist ein Gesetz, was auf der juristischen Basis für den Binnenmarkt aufgesetzt ist. Da kann man schon relativ schnell zu dem Ergebnis kommen. Es ist ein bisschen seltsam, dass der Binnenmarktausschuss nicht irgendeine Verantwortung, Verantwortlichkeit darin hat.
Gibt es noch einen dritten?
Genau, es sind die beiden. Es ist so, dass der Lieberausschuss immer noch federführend ist und der Binnenmarktausschuss sozusagen eine Verantwortung für einen Teil der Artikel hat. Nicht aller. Das ist auch sehr spannend zu wissen. Es gab tatsächlich große Aufregung, es gibt einen Berichterstatter, der einen Draft-Bericht schreibt.
Ein Draft ist eine Art Entwurf?
Genau, ein Entwurf für den Bericht und legt ihm erst mal seinen Ausschuss vor. Als der IMKO-Ausschussbericht rauskam, gab es große Aufregung darum, warum der Innenausschuss nicht Netzsperren gestrichen hat. Das war deswegen der Fall, weil das nicht in der Verantwortlichkeit des Innenmarktausschusses war. Die konnten nichts daran machen. Die haben keine Verantwortlichkeit für Netzsperren in diesem Gesetz. Deswegen war das nicht in diesem Bericht drin. Es ist wichtig zu verstehen, dass sie nicht für alle Artikel in diesem Gesetz zuständig sind. Deswegen haben sie einen bestimmten Handlungsspielraum, wo sie Einfluss nehmen können, wenn es nicht die Hauptverantwortlichkeit des Ausschusses ist. Wir haben gerade schon Berichterstatter gesagt. Deswegen müssen wir erklären, was Berichterstatter sind. Für jedes Gesetz, für jeden Ausschuss gibt es einen verantwortlichen Berichterstatter. Bei der Chatkontrolle ist es Rafi Sasa-Lejos für den Liebeausschuss. Der ist von der EPP, also konservativ. Und Alexander Saliba für den Binnenmarktausschuss. Das sind die Hauptberichterstatter, die den Bericht schreiben.
Du hast vorhin schon gesagt, es gibt Ementment von allen möglichen Leuten.
Das kommt dadurch zustande, dass der Berichterstatter diesen Entwurfsbericht vorlegt, seinem Ausschuss. Es gibt aber für jede Fraktion einen Schattenberichterstatter, der sozusagen für die Fraktionen in diesem Ausschuss sitzt und sich mit dieser Regulierung beschäftigt.
Wenn man von oben drauf guckt, dann ist das natürlich Teil der klassischen Arbeitsteilung in so einem Parlament. Dass man bestimmte Leute, die sich tiefer mit Themen befassen, quasi den Hut aufsetzt. So drückt sich das aus. Bei uns werden, glaube ich, die Obleute, heißen die im Bundestagsausschuss, die sozusagen immer die Fraktion vertreten.
Heißen die auch Berichterstatter? Es kommt darauf an, ob es einen Ausschuss dazu gibt. Dann sind es auch Leute. Da gibt es aber ja Themen, die einfach keinen Ausschuss haben oder quasi so nicht abgebildet sind. Die heißen dann Berichterstatter. Das sind ewig lange Excel-Listen pro Fraktion, wo man nachguckt.
Das ist ja total interessant, wenn du sagst, es gibt ewig lange Excel-Listen pro Fraktion, wo man das nachgucken kann. Im EU-Parlament ist das nicht ganz so einfach. In der Regel weiß man, es gibt halt so ein System, wo du halt nachgucken kannst, was die Schattenberichterstatter für den Hauptausschuss sind. Aber rauszufinden, was die Schattenberichterstatter für die Ausschüsse, die auch irgendwie eine geteilte Verantwortlichkeit haben, ist ziemlich schwer. Das ist wirklich Detektivarbeit. Da muss man die Leute im Parlament, die Leute, den Fraktionen raus, gut kennen, um rauszufinden, wer die Schattenberichterstatterinnen sind, mit denen man sprechen will. Und was halt prozessual passiert ist, der Berichterstatter liegt den Bericht vor. Das war irgendwann um den 16. April im Lieberausschuss. Und dann haben die, ich glaube, vier Wochen sind es ziemlich genau, in der Regelzeit, die Schattenberichterstatter, um Änderungsanträge zu stellen. Das war bis letzten Mittwoch im Lieberausschuss, dass sie die ganzen Änderungsanträge stellen konnten. Und da sind wir jetzt sozusagen. Das heißt, jetzt muss der Berichterstatter, schaut sich sozusagen alle, oder die Mitarbeitenden von dem Berichterstatter, da müssen sich alle Änderungsanträge reingucken. Es sind wirklich viele. Bei der Chatkontrolle sind es, ich glaube, der Bericht von dem Berichterstatter hatte 137 Seiten. Und das ist auch relativ, also wenn man das so sieht, das ist sehr spannend zu sehen. Das ist tabellarisch. Du hast immer auf der einen Seite sozusagen den Originaltext und auf der anderen Seite die Änderungen. Und das kann aber auch sein, dass die neue Sachen hinzufügen, Sachen streichen, irgendein Wording ändern und so weiter und so fort.
Manchmal nennt man nur drei Wörter oder so. Oder eine kurze Hinzufügung oder so. Also es ist auch nicht sortiert nach, wie würde man nennen, nach inhaltlichen großen Änderungen, sondern man muss die selber finden.
Genau, es ist einfach der Gesamttext des Gesetzes. Das ist die Reihenfolge. Wenn man Glück hat, sind die Änderungsanträge wenigstens durchnummeriert. Es gibt aber auch Leute, die einfach nur ihre Änderungen reinschreiben. Das macht es dann viel komplizierter. Danach versucht der Berichterstatter, all diese Änderungsanträge in eine Kompromissform zu bringen. Und dann wird das ganze Ding in dem Ausschuss abgestimmt.
Das ist aber nicht mehr lange hin.
Das dauert noch ein bisschen. Aber ich muss gerade selber gucken. Es ist schon noch ein Stück hin. Ich weiß gerade aus dem Kopf die Abstimmung im Parlament.
Aber ich denke auf jeden Fall noch im Sommer. So lange kann die Frist eigentlich nicht sein. Nach der Sommerpause machen würde ich nicht denken.
Ja, doch, 21.
September. Das ist relativ lang.
Aber das können die sich auch ein bisschen...
Das ist deswegen wichtig, wir haben es schon erwähnt, weil irgendwann wieder neu gewählt wird. Wir haben noch ein Jahr, ungefähr. Dann gibt es ja eine komplette Neuaufstellung dieses Parlaments. Insofern entsteht da ja ein gewisser zeitlicher Druck. Ich hätte gedacht, dass wir das noch im Frühsommer.
Das Problem ist, wir haben das vorhin schon gesagt, selbst in der Kommission gab es sehr kontroverse Debatten über diese Regulierung. Die Diskussionen im Parlament sind auch ähnlich kontrovers. Das ist echt ein Problem. Es gibt wirklich sehr große Streitpunkte. Es gibt nicht nur Streitpunkte in den Ausschüssen, sondern es gibt auch sehr viele Streitpunkte in den Fraktionen selber, weil es da auch ein bisschen zwei Lager immer wieder gibt. An der Stelle kann man vielleicht auch noch mal darüber reden, wie Fraktionen im EU-Parlament eigentlich aussehen. In Deutschland kennen wir ja Fraktionen, Fraktionszwangen.
Es gibt kein Fraktionszwang, wie wir alle wissen. Das ist ja gar kein Zwang, sondern der ist nur Tradition.
Trotzdem wird er manchmal aufgehoben.
Aber, und das finde ich immer sehr, sehr spannend in Europa, zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt die Sozialdemokraten nimmt. Und die deutsche SPD ist jetzt von der politischen Meinung teilweise sehr weit weg. Wie von der schwedischen Sozialdemokraten zum Beispiel.
Man muss sich vorstellen, es gibt die Fraktionen im Parlament, aber sie sind halt nicht so homogen, sondern sehr viel heterogene als man es im deutschen Parlament hat. Und es ist ja viel größer, sollte man auch nicht vergessen. Und die Bündnisse, die sich da zusammentun, sind ein bisschen, mir scheint manchmal auch ein bisschen, aus der Not geboren. Und sie sind teilweise auch hochpolitisch, insbesondere bei den Konservativen. Wo grenzt man sich nach rechts ab und so.
Genau, das ist auch, glaube ich, wieder so ein bisschen dieses, wie bei uns Fraktionszwang-Tradition, sind manche Fraktionen im EU-Parlament auch so ein bisschen, wir haben halt irgendwie Sozialdemokraten in unserem Namen. Und deswegen gehören wir irgendwie traditionell zusammen. Das Spektrum ist halt aber einfach wirklich enorm, was man in so einer Fraktionenlande ist.
Ja, und auch natürlich, wie sich Wien die repräsentieren. Das sind ja nun mal Volksvertreter. Und also, Europa ist halt auch wirklich groß. Ein riesiger Kontinent mit viel unterschiedlichen, auch kulturellen und politkulturellen, ja, so Entstehungsgeschichten. Ja je, und dann kommt dann noch die ganze, muss man aber auch nicht vergessen, es gibt auch einen Teil der Parlamentarier, die sind echt europakritisch. Hab ich ja nur selber auch schon in den Ausschüssen erlebt. Die sind da auch alle drin.
Also vielleicht eine kleine, sehr lustige Anekdote. Also eigentlich ist sie überhaupt nicht lustig. Aber als der, ja, wir müssen, als der Bericht vom Lieberausschuss vorgestellt wurde, das habe ich mir natürlich angeguckt, weil dann halten halt die Einzelnen, also haben die Möglichkeit, die Schattenberichterstatter die Möglichkeit, noch einen Wortbeitrag dazu bringen, aber auch einfach generell Mitglieder des Ausschusses für Wortbeiträge. Und dann habe ich so rumgewitselt, weil es eine Abgeordnete von den Rechten gab, die Mussolini hieß. Und Fun Fact, die Enkeltochter, das ist die Enkeltochter von Mussolini, die im EU-Parlament sitzt für die Rechten.
Die ist aber relativ bekannt in Italien.
Die ist relativ bekannt in Italien. Aber ich war sehr schockiert davon, ich wusste es vorher nicht, habe da noch einen Witz drüber gemacht und gesagt, das ist ja ein Zufall, das wäre ja lustig, wenn... Und Ella, meine Kollegin von E3, sagte zu mir, das ist die.
Na ja, gut, das muss man sehen. Die Ministerpräsidentin von Italien ist ja nun...
Natürlich, aber ich fand es schon sehr beeindruckend, dass Mussolinis Enkeltochter was zur Chatkontrolle zu sagen hat. Und es war nichts Gutes, muss ich auch... Spoiler.
Wir kriegen hier nun verbare Zeichen, dass wir uns sputen müssen. Aber wir wollen schon...
Wir wollen noch Themen ansprechen, wie zum Beispiel den informellen Trilog.
Aber ich würde vorher noch einmal kurz zu der Abstimmung in dem Ausschuss und wie es dann weitergeht. Also, Constanze hat ja gerade gesagt, dass sie gedacht hätte, dass es ein bisschen schneller geht. Es ist relativ kontrovers, deswegen wird es wahrscheinlich erst im September so weit sein. Und wir möchten natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen aufzeigen, wann ist eigentlich ein guter Zeitpunkt, mit meinen Abgeordneten zu sprechen. Und es ist halt so, dass dieser Bericht im Ausschuss abgestimmt wird. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Handlungsempfehlung auch an das Parlament, diese Abstimmung aus dem Ausschuss. Das heißt, es ist total sinnvoll, vor September nochmal mit Abgeordneten zu sprechen, die im Lieberausschuss sitzen und irgendwie die Argumente deutlich zu machen, damit wir der Report von, also der Bericht, der Entwurfsbericht von dem Berichterstatter ist jetzt leider nicht so gut ausgefallen, muss ich sagen. Der vom Binnenmarktausschuss ist ein guter Bericht und auch eine gute Grundlage, der im Lieberausschuss leider nicht. Und da wird es natürlich unheimlich viele, auch ich glaube sehr gute Änderungsanträge geben. Und die muss man halt auch nochmal ein bisschen bestärken und auch nochmal gucken, dass man da Abgeordnete erreicht. Man kann relativ einfach rausfinden, welches der verantwortliche Abgeordnete für seinen Wahlkreis ist. Und man kann, das gibt von dem EU-Parlament für jeden Abgeordneten immer so eine Profilseite. Und da steht tatsächlich auch einfach, in welchem Ausschuss die Person drin ist.
Das ist eh nicht verkehrt zu wissen, der eigene Abgeordnete im EU-Parlament ist nicht wahr. Also es lohnt sich ja auch sonst mal, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Der repräsentiert mich da eigentlich nicht mal. Genau.
Also das vielleicht dazu.
Man ist ja sogar noch über die Sommerferienzeit hier aktiv zu werden.
Genau. Und im Oktober wird es dann ins Parlament vollgehen. So sieht es derzeit aus. Es kann aber sein, dass sich das auch noch weiter verzögert aufgrund der großen Kontroverse um dieses Thema.
Ich hatte mir mal die Zahlen angesehen. Mehr so aus Interesse. Ich habe es euch schon erzählt vorhin. 19 Monate ist derzeit der schnitt von, also statistischer schnitt von, der Initiativrecht wird gebraucht. Also da geht ein Gesetzgebungsprozess los bis durch. Vor allem doch relativ schnell, weil ich eher überrascht. Wenn man das jetzt nehmen würde für die Chatkontrolle als Durchschnittswert, dann wird sie dann gut in der Mitte dabei. Also könnten sie das noch hinkriegen.
Ja, man muss natürlich sagen, also jetzt noch eine letzte Einordnung und dann kommen wir zum Trilog. Das ist total spannend. Auch im Rat wird sehr kontrovers gestritten. Und der Rat ist auch noch nicht so wirklich weit gekommen in ihren Verhandlungen. Also das ist jetzt so ein richtig krasses Nerdwissen. Die wirklich interessanten Artikel und die problematischen Artikel sind so Artikel 7 bis 11 in der Chatkontrollengesetzgebung. Es gibt noch so Artikel 3 und 4, die auch relativ spannend sind, aber 7 bis 11 sind die, die besonders kritisch und kontrovers diskutiert werden. Und tatsächlich ist der Rat noch nicht zu diesen Artikeln gekommen. Das heißt, der Rat wird auch noch...
Aber darüber weiß man faktisch trotzdem am wenigsten. Also der Ausschuss ist ja eigentlich da, wo man am meisten Einblick hat und der EU-Rat ist da, wo relativ viel Intransparenz ist, wo es nicht mal eine ordentliche Protokollierung gibt, wo in Neig, würde man sagen, eigentlich immer nur noch, wenn man Glück hat, ein ordentliches Ergebnis, aber nicht etwa der Prozess, der zu dem Ergebnis geführt hat, öffentlich ist. Da ist ja sozusagen am wenigsten Beteiligung möglich.
Genau, und das ist vielleicht auch noch mal interessant, zu den Drahtberichten zu sagen. Wenn man so einen Drahtbericht vorliegen hat, dann würde man vielleicht denken, cool, das ist total vollständig und dann hat man einen guten Blick. In einem deutschen Drahtbericht wird halt immer drin stehen, Deutschland hat sich beteiligt wie angewiesen.
Also es lohnt sich mal, Drahtberichte zu lesen. Ich kann ja mal kurz Werbung machen auf netzpolitik.org, wo ich zufällig arbeite. Da haben wir einige der Drahtberichte, aber auch sonst Drahtberichte. Und die sind interessant, weil sie auch wieder eine Zusammenfassung der Positionen sind. Die sind auch nicht eben ausführlich oder lang.
Und was auch ganz furchtbar ist, dass die deutschen Leute in ihren Drahtberichten andere Länderkürze benutzen, als die, die international funktionieren. Das hat bei uns schon intern total viel Verwirrung gesorgt, weil ich manchmal dann die Kürze durcheinander schmeiße, wenn ich gerade so einen Drahtbericht zusammenfasse. Die sind halt auf Deutsch die Drahtberichte. Das heißt, wenn Netzpolitik sich nicht netterweise übersetzt, dann schreibe ich englische Zusammenfassungen für meine Kollegen in Brüssel teilweise, damit wir halt irgendwie ein vollständiges Tracking der Position im Rat haben. Und das kann zu sehr großer Verwirrung führen. Und wir versuchen dann halt auch immer noch an Drahtberichte von anderen Ländern zu kommen, um rauszufinden, wie Deutschland sich denn jetzt wirklich verhalten hat. Weil das ist für uns ja dann meistens das Interessante. Und das steht halt in den deutschen Drahtberichten einfach nicht drin.
Also jedes Land hat ja im Prinzip so einen Drahtbericht. Wobei, sag ich mal, ich weiß zumindest von einigen der anderen Länder, dass die unterschiedlich lang ausfallen und so. Aber das ist auch noch eine Ebene, die wäre ja eine klassische Kritik wert. Das hat der Bereich, der opark ist, auch wenn man daran mitwirken will. Aber eben ein entscheidender Bereich, denn da findet eben auch in großem Maße politische Meinungsbildung statt.
Und das ist vielleicht auch noch was, ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, dass es schwer Schattenberichterstatter für Ausschüsse rauszubekommen, die nicht die federführenden Ausschüsse sind. Es ist auch sehr schwer, rauszufinden, wer die permanenten Repräsentanten, die im Rat daran arbeiten sind. Das ist wirklich, das ist so Scheller-Cohle-Level 120, das rauszubekommen und dann, wenn man den Namen rausbekommen hat, rauszufinden, wie man irgendwelche Kontaktdaten von denen kommt.
Und die sind ja auch keine Abgeordneten oder Mitarbeiter von Abgeordneten, sondern Beamte.
Das sind halt einfach Beamten und da muss man echt Glück haben und irgendwie Netzwerkeffekte nutzen. Die sind dann aber manchmal tatsächlich doch auch bereit zu reden. Am Ende des Tages wird man sie aber nicht umstimmen können, das muss man halt auch immer sagen, weil die sind halt weisungsgebunden an das, was die Regierungen sagen. Und jetzt kommen wir...
Ich denke, wir lassen den Trilog weg. Weil wir sind, also ich glaube, wir schaffen nicht mehr, wir müssen eigentlich über den Trilog reden, weil der Trilog immer eine Rolle spielt, aber bei der Chatkontrolle, die wir jetzt als Beispiel haben, da sind wir noch gar nicht so. Und dann würden wir doch einfach sagen, wir vertragen uns. Denn der Trilog ist auch in anderen EU-Gesetzgebungsprozessen interessant, auch weil er sich verändert hat. Es gibt diesen formellen Trilog und den informellen Trilog. Aber ich würde auch mal sagen, wir lassen ihn weg und fordern stattdessen unsere Hörer und Hörerinnen auf, gute Darstellungen des formellen und informellen Trilogs, die nicht in der Wikipedia stehen, meine Lieben, an uns zu senden und uns zu sagen, ob wir das noch machen wollen. In den Kommentaren bei chaosradio.de. Wie wäre das? Wäre das eine schlaue Idee?
Auf jeden Fall. Vielleicht auch noch eine weitere Sache. Ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, dass in Österreich das Parlament eine bündende Entscheidung treffen kann zu den Fahnen durch den Rat. Das Spannende ist, jetzt komme ich wieder mit Lieblingsartikeln, nach Artikel 23 des Grundgesetzes kann der Deutsche Bundestag auch zwar eine nicht bündende, aber eine Weisung zu Verhalten oder zu Abstimmungsverhalten im Rat machen. Da kann man sich auch politisch positionieren. Und das ist bisher noch nicht geschehen. Das ist bei der aktuellen Positionierung der Bundesregierung, das kann man vielleicht auch noch mal kurz beleuchten. Die Bundesregierung hat sich positioniert, teilweise ganz gut im Hinblick auf den Schutz von verschütteter Kommunikation.
Teilweise sehr deutlich. Wenn man mal die Minister nennen, die hier zu nennen sind, ist einmal Wissing und einmal Buschmann. Also Buschmann als Justizminister von der FDP und Wissing als Digitalminister, wie sie jetzt auch immer sagen. Auch von der FDP, die haben das schon sehr deutlich eräußert.
Die haben sich sehr deutlich geäußert.
Was ist denn mit unserer Innenministerin von der SPD?
Also es ist ja auch total spannend, dass die Sachverständige in der Anhörung, die Sachverständige der SPD in der Anhörung im Bundes-, im Digitalausschuss sehr stark...
Ja, ich hau mir jetzt, mach keinen Insider, sag, wer das war.
Also ich wurde von der SPD in den Digitalausschuss geladen als Expertin zu dem Thema Chatkontrolle. Und ich habe da auch sehr deutlich unsere Positionen und meine Einschätzung dazu vorgetragen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein offener Konflikt in der SPD.
Ja, aber die Innenministerin hat in vielen digitalpolitischen Fragen offenen Konflikt in der SPD. Die ist die zerrissenste der Parteien von den drei, muss man schon deutlich sagen. Aber sie ist auch offenbar sehr wirkmächtig.
Um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, es ist halt total egal, was unsere Innenministerin macht. Das Parlament könnte trotzdem diese Artikel 23-Abstimmung mal anstoßen, um einfach den Druck ein bisschen zu erhöhen. Weil die Positionierung der Bundesregierung, die wir haben, ist ein Teil, auf den sie sich einigen konnten, ist sehr gut. Der andere Teil ist halt agree to disagree. Eine Positionierung wird irgendwie noch stattfinden. Deswegen verhalten wir uns dazu irgendwie.
Würde man nicht wieder generalisieren können, zu sagen, eigentlich sollte sich ein deutscher Parlament und andere europäische Parlamente häufiger direkt positionieren zu Gesetzgebungsvorhaben? Nö, wollen wir hier ein bisschen meter. Wir wollen mal ein bisschen ja, hm?
Also, ich, ich... Also, ja, ich glaube auch, vor allen Dingen ist es wichtig zu verstehen. Ich finde, manchmal fühlt sich ja die EU und auch das EU-Parlament sehr weit weg und sehr abstrakt an. Man muss aber auch immer sagen, und das kann ich auch nicht aufhören zu betonen, dass wir auch, ich sag mal, bei uns zu Hause mit unseren gewählten Vertreterinnen in der Regierung und im Bundestag auch schon eine Menge bewegen können. Und das muss man halt auch immer beachten. Gerade in Deutschland, Deutschland ist ein sehr, sehr mächtiges Land, wenn es um EU-Dinge kommt. Wir sind eines der größten Länder.
Wirtschaftsstark, den ganzen Länderleien.
Es gibt ja auch sozusagen, wenn im Rat, es gibt einen Voting-Calculator für den Rat und das geht ja nach prozentualem Bevölkerungsanteil der EU. Das heißt, wir haben natürlich einen relativ hohen Prozentanteil, deswegen fällt unsere Stimme auch relativ schwer ins Gewicht. Um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, ihr könnt halt auch, indem ihr eure Bundestagsabgeordneten kontaktiert, Einfluss auf EU-Gesetz zu nehmen. Und es wäre jetzt in dieser Chatkontrolle auch sehr, sehr angemessen, sich vielleicht auch einfach mal die Abgeordneten in eurem Wahlkreis vorzunehmen, die für euch im Bundestag sitzen und zu sagen so, Leute, wir sind überhaupt nicht zufrieden mit der Positionierung der Bundesregierung. Ihr seid unsere gewählten Vertreterinnen. Macht da was. Ihr könnt was machen.
Und wir haben diesmal ja ein Beispiel. Und wir haben auch gerade ein österreichisches Beispiel, weil der vielleicht immer noch, weil eben auch deutschsprachig ist, weil vielleicht auch am ehesten noch wahrgenommen wurde. Ich fand das ganz bemerkenswert. Es liegt jetzt aber schon Monate zurück, ich finde.
Wann haben wir das gemacht? Im Dezember oder so? Oder im Oktober? Nee, im Oktober. Und das ist auch das Interessante in Österreich, dass alle Parteien sich einzeln einig waren. Und die Einzigen, die dagegen gestimmt haben, waren sie Konservativen, aber nur, weil sie noch extremer dagegen vorgehen wollten.
Ich denke ja auch, dass bei uns eine Mehrheit gegen diese Vorschläge wäre. Ich glaube, die Informiertheit ist bei uns in Deutschland auch relativ groß, weil die Presse doch eben auch auf Deutsch viel berichtet hat. Also eine ist, was wir zum Ende hin sagen wollen. Man braucht sich nicht fürchten vor dieser EU. Auch da gibt es Prozesse, die kann man lernen, so wie wir heute viel wissen über parlamentarische Prozesse in der Bundesrepublik. Die kriegt man einfach mit. Teilweise kriegt man sie schon in der Schule gelehrt. Bei manchen Menschen, so finde ich, braucht man sich in der EU eigentlich nicht fürchten. Man muss es kennen, wenn man Einfluss nehmen will oder sich für manche interessiert. Aber man kann auch, wir haben kurz darüber gesprochen, man kann sich natürlich auch Institutionen zuwenden, die sich da kümmern. Edri wäre ein Beispiel. Wir werden vielleicht im Zuge des Podcasts Dicke Bretter noch zu anderen Organisationen kommen. Aber ich glaube, man muss sich hier nicht fürchten. Man muss sich aber auch informieren. Immer nur meckern über die EU, finde ich keinen guten Weg.
Ja, und ich glaube, dass auch irgendwie diese Frustration mit der EU teilweise dazu zustande kommt, weil man halt den fehlenden Blick hinter die Kulissen hat. Und dann manchmal versucht, an Punkten anzusetzen, wo ich halt dann auch ganz ehrlich sagen muss...
Das war nicht der gute Punkt.
Das war jetzt total frustrierend für dich. Und das ist total schade, weil du hast halt einen total wichtigen Punkt und auch inhaltlich total richtigen Punkt. Aber wenn du denen an, keine Ahnung, jetzt im Hinblick kurz vor einer Abstimmung in dem spezifischen Fachausschuss bei dem Abgeordneten untergebracht hättest, dann wärst du wahrscheinlich viel zufriedener da rausgegangen und hättest auch viel mehr Wirkmächtigkeit gehabt. Oder wenn du halt irgendwie vor der Abstimmung im Parlament mit deinem Parlamentarier gesprochen hättest oder zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt irgendwie eine Demo organisiert hättest oder so. Also ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch so wichtig, auch wenn das immer alles total erschlagend klingt, es ist am Ende kein Hexenwerk. Und wenn man es verstanden hat, dann kann man sich auch total gut einbringen, ohne dass man komplett frustriert sein muss von der ganzen Geschichte.
Also sich zu informieren, schallt ja sowieso nicht.
Man sollte eh mal wissen, wo man den Bohrer ansetzt, um die Dicken Bretter am Ende auch zu erledigen, um die Metapher mal bis zum Ende durchzureiten.
Wir hoffen, wir konnten motivieren dazu. Und wir wollen diese Reihe, Dicke Bretter, wie unser Podcast heißt, wir wollen die fortsetzen. Wollen wir schon verraten, unser nächstes Thema? Oder wollen wir geheim bleiben? Ich sehe schon, ja, wir bleiben total geheim. Ich kriege hier nur ein verbales Zeichen.
Der Rat der Dicke Bretter muss noch verhandeln. Drahtbericht folgt.
Okay, in der nächsten Reihenfolge ist wieder ein reguläres Chaosradio dran. Dann im Juli. Wissen wir aber auch noch nicht, was inhaltlich passiert. Also können wir noch nicht teasern. Wir bedanken uns jedenfalls jetzt schon. Wenn ihr Kommentare ins Blog packt und hoffen, dass wir euch gut informiert haben. Und dann bedanken wir uns nochmal bei Erdgeist. Und natürlich bei der Crew vom Chaosradio. Bei Erdgeist für die Musik und bei der Crew vom Chaosradio, die ja die Produktion übernimmt. Und auch nochmal bei Markus Richter, an dem wir die Einleitung sprechen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.